que lleva amnistía internacional al
señalar que la represión durante el
estallido social ha tenido un sesgo
racista
Bueno lo que hemos analizado y es por lo
que decimos que ha habido ataques
generalizados en contra de la población
pero que además han tenido este sesgo
marcadamente racista contra personas
indígenas contra personas racializadas
contra personas campesinas es porque
realizamos un análisis Respecto a los
índices de homicidios verdad de muertes
que habían sido causados presuntamente
por la policía y el ejército durante las
manifestaciones y los niveles de
violencia en las manifestaciones en
distintas regiones y por ejemplo en
regiones como Lima
donde los niveles de violencia
registrados en las manifestaciones eran
similares a los niveles por ejemplo de
regiones como puno guayacucho sin
embargo estas últimas regiones que
concentran la mayoría de las personas
indígenas del país habían de alguna
manera acumulado el mayor porcentaje de
muertes verdad esto quiere decir que
esto nos indica que efectivamente hay un
mercado sesgo racista porque no se actúa
y la policía no actúa de la misma manera
cuando la población no está racializada
que cuando la población lo está aparte
de esto hemos visto discursos sumamente
racistas por parte de las autoridades
Vimos a la presidenta Dina boluarte
incluso afirmar que la región de puno no
es Perú hemos visto como se estigmatiza
cómo se criminaliza diciendo que los
manifestantes son terroristas son
criminales sin que el estado haya
aportado ninguna prueba y es por eso que
consideramos que hay un mercado sesgo
discriminatorio en esta en esta
actuación en el informe señalan además
que este tipo de discurso estigmatizante
socava el acceso a la justicia
explíquenos un poco más esta denuncia
Exacto tiene muchas vertientes pero es
desde una cuestión de cómo las
autoridades estigmatizan como las
autoridades generan obstáculos para que
las personas lleguen primero por lo que
digo cuando a uno se le ataca de
terrorista de criminal en los medios
públicos al más alto nivel del Estado
difícilmente La gente va a acudir a las
autoridades del Estado a poner una
denuncia porque lo que las personas las
víctimas creen es que en vez de escuchar
su caso en vez de hacer justicia estas
autoridades más bien les van a perseguir
les van a abrir una carpeta por
terrorismo por daño la vía pública por
cualquier otra cuestión que nada tiene
que ver con violaciones a los derechos
humanos y hay otra cuestión y es el tema
del idioma no hemos visto que muchos
obstáculos en hospitales en instancias
del Estado estamos hablando de población
que es mayoritariamente que chohablante
y que han tenido muchos obstáculos no a
la hora de relacionarse con la autoridad
sigue habiendo estos obstáculos Y es por
eso que que vemos como como esta
población lo tiene más difícil además
hemos identificado una cuestión bien
importante si es el tema de acceso a la
salud durante año venimos denunciando
que el sistema sanitario en Perú está
infra este
infra presupuestado prácticamente nos
invierte en estas regiones del sur
particularmente donde las protestas han
tenido mayor protagonismo el sistema de
salud es sumamente eficiente los médicos
y nosotros lo hemos visto trabajan en
condiciones la verdad lamentables sin
recursos entonces vemos que para que
digamos salgan adelante las víctimas no
tan o sea tanto en temas de acceso a la
justicia como en temas médicos de
reparación de rehabilitación se necesita
una inyección por parte del Estado y
empezar a tomar más en serio más en
cuenta a todas estas poblaciones a lo
largo del país
bueno está dando ya quizás una
recomendación al Estado peruano pero una
vez hecha la denuncia que otras
recomendaciones harían al gobierno y al
estado en general de Perú
la primera ha sido el fese a la
represión nos parece que si no se
generan condiciones
digamos de paz de tranquilidad un
ambiente sosegado para mantener un
diálogo es imposible que se salga de
esta crisis no puede ser que se vuelvan
a dar capítulos como el que se vivió en
puno donde en una sola jornada 17
personas fallecieron una manifestación
es decir esto es una condición
fundamental y a lo que la presidenta
Dina en la reunión que tuvimos
personalmente con ella se comprometió lo
segundo es el tema de las
investigaciones penales vemos un serio
retraso en las investigaciones vemos
como las fiscalías regionales la de
ayacucho la de andahuaylas no tienen
recursos hablamos con los fiscales Y la
verdad casi no hay personal no tienen
peritos Hay ciertos peritajes de los que
dependen de Lima para que se puedan
realizar esto ha demorado muchísimo la
investigación Pero además está sufriendo
un obstáculo porque la evidencia se
Esta es otra recomendación importante la
tercera es el tema de el racismo
estructural que vemos nos parece que hay
que tomar medidas inmediatas no hay que
empezar a pensar en qué está fallando no
en temas de acceso a la salud en temas
de derechos sociales en temas de
reconocimiento a estas poblaciones
indígenas campesinas racializadas y
necesariamente viene por una política
estructural del estado y además hemos
pedido a la comunidad internacional
acciones urgentes No necesitamos que la
comunidad internacional se active